President Trump recently ended DACA, the program
protecting nearly 700,000 undocumented immigrants
whose families brought them to the United
States when they were children.
The program will be in place for the next
six months, giving Congress time to provide
a legislative solution for these undocumented
immigrants, commonly called Dreamers.
A study published by the Cato Institute finds
that over the next decade, DACA recipients
will add hundreds of billions of dollars to
the economy, and billions of dollars to the
federal Treasury.
Many hold good paying jobs.
They spend money in their communities, supporting
employment themselves.
A large share are pursuing higher education,
and will add significant value to the economy
when they finish their undergraduate or graduate
degree.
But more is at stake than economics.
The United States gave the Dreamers security,
relieving them of the fear of a knock on the
door one day, a life shattered, a forceful
return to a country they do not know.
Once given, a great nation doesn’t take
that assurance away.
A morally serious nation doesn’t extend
the hand of welcome to someone one day and
then shove him out the door the next.
Congress should act to protect
the Dreamers.
To learn more about my take on DACA and the dreamers, check the links
check the links in the description below. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.